megan and harry are proud parents to
baby lily
and their second child's name pays
tribute to her late grandmother princess
diana
on sunday it was announced the duke and
duchess of sussex
have welcomed their daughter lillabet
lilly diana mountbatten windsor
born on june 4th in santa barbara
california the couple have been residing
in nearby montecito with two-year-old
son
archie the royal family's official
instagram shared this statement
saying quote congratulations to the duke
and duchess of sussex
on the birth of lillabet diana the queen
the prince of wales and the duchess of
cornwall
and the duke and duchess of cambridge
are delighted with the news
i'm sure they've probably got a very
good idea of what they're going to call
their little girl
and i think many people are expecting
that diana is going to be
one of her names in leading up to lily's
birth
there was already speculation that
harry's mother princess diana
would be a source of inspiration for
their daughter's name
i absolutely think that they will want
to include diana or maybe not at her
first name but
i'm sure it's very high up on the list
in terms of the second
christian name and i think that's quite
simply because it would be
for harry a wonderful way to pay tribute
to his mother and i think
it's very likely to be chosen as a
middle name
in a statement from the royal couple we
learned how the newborn's name
also honors another close member of the
royal family
it reads quote lily is named after her
great-grandmother her majesty the queen
whose family nickname is lillabet her
middle name diana
was chosen to honor her beloved late
grandmother the princess of wells
the statement goes on to say that lily
weighed seven pounds 11 ounces
and both mother and child are healthy
and well lillabet is very familiar to
royal historians
the name was given to queen elizabeth by
her father king george iv
as the future monarch had trouble
pronouncing her own name at a young age
megan and harry also enclosed a special
message of gratitude for their
supporters
writing in the announcement quote on
june 4th we were blessed with the
arrival of our daughter lily
she is more than we could have ever
imagined and we remain grateful for the
love and prayers we felt from across the
globe
thank you for your continued kindness
and support during this very special
time for our family
well absolutely megan is going to take
some maternity leave she didn't have
much maternity leave last time round but
i'm told
second time round she's actually going
to make a point of
taking some time out enjoying this time
and
prince harry's also going to take his
paternity leave too
and this is actually the second time
diana's name has been honored by her two
boys
when princess charlotte was born in 2015
prince william and kate middleton
also included diana in her full name
charlotte elizabeth diana mountbatten
windsor
amid the reported rift between harry and
william following harry and megan
exiting the royal family in 2020
as well as the couple's headline making
interview with oprah winfrey
many have voiced hope that their new
bundle of joy could help men some of
their hurt feelings
well i think there's always the hope
that a new baby
will help to heal any risks they're
obviously a source of
absolute joy and you know william and
kate will be
incredibly excited to be welcoming and a
niece into the family
the first girl for harry and megan and i
think everyone hopes that
by the time this little girl arrives
there will have been more conversations
and they will be in a better place and
of course harry's due to come over in
july
for the unveiling of the diana statue so
i think there are opportunities for
a better relationship between the
[Music]
brothers
you